not even the most optimistic scientists
dead to hope the first covid vaccine
could be this effective
clinical trials have shown the prototype
made by pfizer
and bion tech is 90 percent effective
the companies are planning to apply for
emergency approval to start rolling out
the vaccine
from the end of the month 10 million
doses should be in the uk stockpile by
the end of the year
with another 30 million to follow we
absolutely cannot rely on
this news as a solution and the biggest
mistake
we could make now would be to slacken
our resolve at a critical moment
more than 43 000 people in six countries
were given either the vaccine
or a placebo jab and then trapped to see
how many
caught covid the company still has to
analyze safety data
but no significant problems have been
seen so far
the hopes of billions of people and
millions and
businesses and hundreds of governments
that were
felt on our shoulders now we can
credibly try them i think we can see
light at the end of the time
the vaccine is code named bnt 162
b2 it's given as two doses three weeks
apart
it contains a small piece of rna the
viruses genetic code
which instructs human cells to make the
viral spike
protein triggering an immune response
it's technology never used before
and it should be quicker to scale up
than traditional vaccines
but one expert warned the company still
needs to prove the protection
lasts and that it works in older people
that's crucial if it doesn't protect
against the
disease in the elderly or older 55 plus
then it's not going to have a big impact
on mortality and that's clearly what we
want to see
there are 10 vaccines in late stage
clinical trials
oxford university and astrazeneca are
due to reveal how well their prototype
works by the end of the year
they were one of the first half of the
blocks in the spring but were overtaken
by pfizer
it really isn't a race at all for the
the world we need to have multiple
successful vaccines and i don't think
any of us have
been going into this trying to be first
what we want is to make sure that
there's global
eco equitable access to vaccines
the vaccine still has much to prove but
scientists
are optimistic that those most
vulnerable to disease can be protected
by the spring
that would reduce the burden on the nhs
and put both the economy
and our lives back on track thomas more
sky news